it's been over a month since a series of
new medical care services have been
accessible to unhoused people in the
downtown area well 8 news now got an
inside look at the Neighborhood clinic
and how dope services are making a
difference to getting those back on
their feet
it's just one day at a time for me like
I just want to be a better me Shannon
Griffin has been living at the Las Vegas
rescue mission for the past two years as
she works to overcome personal struggles
but says catching a cold is common being
around so many people because we get
sick a lot you know with all the kids
and stuff and just us being around each
other we do we get sick often we might
actually last month The Neighborhood
clinic opened its doors at the Las Vegas
Rescue Mission campus off Bonanza and D
Street offering free medical care and
screenings to unhoused people who would
normally travel miles away to see a
doctor do on-site Pharmacy delivery we
do on-site Imaging and we're also trying
to integrate other Specialists to come
on site you know this clientele would
need a bus pass the area is known for a
high concentration of people without a
home insurance or Transportation with
little to no access to health care
according to Dan Briggs founder of the
neighborhood Clinic what this is truly
doing is laying the foundation of what
we're trying to achieve next year in the
years that follow in 2023 we expect to
open up 10 more neighborhood clinics
throughout the Las Vegas Valley and all
underserved areas you take them two two
and a half hours every single day today
the former medical building is
undergoing a major renovation with
repairs being made to the roof and
Landscaping a touch of Hope to those
struggling to push ahead everybody who's
been through stuff you know none of us
are perfect and uh when you really want
to change you know God will put things
in your life